okay in this video I'm gonna talk to you
about the physical and chemical barriers
to infection so this is my very simple
diagram of a person and I'm going to
start off by talking about the physical
barriers and we have one very fantastic
physical barrier which is the skin and
the skin is really effective because it
stops microorganisms from getting in and
if the skin was ever to be damaged let's
say by a cut our blood is is very smart
because it
oops silly me it clots and if you
remember it's plate blitz they are in
the blood that caused the clotting and
the clotting quickly seals a cut and
keeps any mark microorganisms from
getting in
so that's skin and and also the fact
that that blood will clot when we do
break the barrier and then we've got our
oh we've got another physical barrier
actually and that is imagine that is the
mouth here is the digest or not the
digestive what am I talking about
this is the trachea okay so it breaks up
into my my my bronchus and here's my
lungs here's my two lungs now the trick
here is is a wonderful thing and
actually the whole respiratory tract
here because it is lined with cilia and
if you remember I'm going to do a little
zoom in here of what cilia look like
very thin hair like projections
that line the whole tract and with the
help of mucus that is also in the
respiratory tract which will catch any
invading bacteria or dust particles or
anything gets trapped in the mucus and
then the cilia can effectively push the
mucus up and out of the lungs and and
away from from this lung tissue here
that's really important so that's that's
another physical barrier and then we've
got two chemical barriers that you need
to know about and one of them is in is
in the eyes and if you get something in
your eye what happens to you your eyes
start to water and you produce some
tears and oh that doesn't look like an a
your tears will have enzymes basically
called Lizer zone for Liza's I'm sorry
lysozyme which killed bacteria
as it touches the surface of the skin
and you also have this is not very
anatomically correct but also in here
that is connected to your esophagus that
kind of runs parallel to the the
windpipe
you've got your stomach now your stomach
is a really important chemical defense
because if you eat any food that
contains pathogens paths o Gian's and
remember pathogens are disease-causing
microorganisms I'm going to abbreviate
that to microbes because it's the same
thing
disease-causing microbes so if your food
contains microbes that cause disease
because the stomach is made or it
contains hydrochloric acid which is
about pH one to two this kills pathogens
pathogens keep spelling that wrong
pathogens
upon entering the stuff or upon entering
the stomach so that they don't cause
harm later in the body